So above this dotted line, I have a certain number of boxes.
And we could see each of these gold bars, they have 10 boxes in them. 1, 2, 3...
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10
And I have two groups of these tens. So I have two tens.
I have two tens and I have 1, 2, 3 ones.
That's how many boxes I have above that line and below that line...
I have 1, 2, 3, 4 tens.
Four tens.
And I have 1,2,3,4,5...
I have five ones.
So, this first number is two tens and three ones or 23.
Two tens, three ones. The second number is four tens and five ones.
Four tens and five ones...45, now, what I want to do is add the numbers.
So let's do that. So let's add, so let's
add that amount. This amount to this amount.
23 to 45.
Well, I have three ones here, I have five ones here, so if you add those to those you're going to end up with
eight ones.
So let me do that in that blue color.
So you're gonna have: 1,
2, 3, 4, ...
5, 6, 7, 8 and if we look at it...
look at it over here where we write down the numbers with digits,
or with numerals. Then here you're gonna have three ones plus five ones
is eight ones. Eight ones... eight ones.
Now you have two tens plus four tens.
Well, that's going to be six tens. So let me actually copy and paste this.
So I have two tens.
So two plus four is six. So two,
four and...
two, four and six.
So I have... I have.
Let me change my tools. So
I have
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 tens
Woops, using the wrong thing. I have...
I have
six tens. So just like that,
you can see when I had 23 to 45, I just added the ones place. Three plus five was eight.
Three plus five is eight. Three ones plus five ones is eight ones.
And I added the tens place.
Two tens plus four tens is equal to 6 tens.
So I got 68.